اذا ناقشنا نتيجه لابحاثك حول التطورات
الصينيه في مجال الذكاء الاصطناعي تحديدا
لوين ممكن ان نتجه
لا احد
الكره بلوريه او لا استطيع قراءه المستقبل
ولكن ما نعرفه الى الان هو ان كايفولي
الخبير الصيني في ذكاء الصناعي وذكر في
كتابه القوى الخارقه في الذكاء الاصطناعيه
قل بان الشركات الصينيه بها السمعه في
تحويل التكنولوجيا التجاريه من ضمنها حتى
ذكاء الاصطناعي ولكن الصيني لم تكن
الرائده في العالم في ابتكار تكنولوجة
جديده كل هذا صحيح ولا جدل في ذلك ولكن
هنالك ادله في كتابنا ساريكم اياه وهو
القوى الصينيه وذكاء الاصطناعي
وان هذا نموذج بدا يتغير
تشاهدته مشهورات علميه ومؤتمرات علميه
وابحاثه
لمختبراتك صناعه من الدوله او خاصه الصين
تحقق وتقدمها كبيره في مجالات متقدم ذكاء
الاصطناعي لمعالجه المشاكل في هذا المجال
باستخدام الاساليب الابداع
تتبعوا
الممارسات المعموله بها
خلصت لان الصين تنتهج استراتيجيه وطنيه
لقياده العالم في مجال الذكاء الاصطناعي
بحلول عام
2030 وهذا كان يعني في في احد في واحد من
دراسات التي نشرت عنك ما هي ميزات هذا
المشروع الصيني
لغايه 2015
لم تعترف بالذكاء الاصطناعي ولم تعده
كمجال له الاولويه اجرى الاصطناعي ولكن
دائما ما كان له صله بشيء اخر هذا التغير
في عام 2017
حيث
اصدر خطه وطنيه مكثفه لتطوير الذكاء
الاصطناعي وهذه الخطا طويله ولا حتى ارفع
صفحاتها ولكنها تغطي كافه المجالات
المرتبطه بذكاء الاصطناعي وعبروا وبكل
وضوح في تلك الوثيقه ان هدفهم
للتغلب على العالم فكره الاصطناعي بحلول
عشرين ثلاثين
راجعنا الخطه وبشكل خاص لما يحصل الان في
الصين وتقدمها في الذكاء الاصطناعي وحددنا
ثلاثه مقاربات
نرى اتخاذ الصيني لها
الصناعي احداها التقليديه وهي على
البيانات الكبرى
وهي الان تنافس بقيه العالم في درجه
تعقيدها وتقدمها كما يبحثون ايضا عن كتب
فيما يسمى بالذكاء الاصطناعي تلهم من
الدماغ ومستوحى من الدماغ ومقاربه ذلك
مختلفه فيحاول ان يحاكي الاجراءات
البيولوجيه والطبيعيه لخلق ذكاء اصطناعي
اكثر قدره مجال اخر تعرفنا عليه
واجهات الدماغ الحاسوبيه الروابط بين
الدماغ الانساني
والكمبيوترات تعمل في هذا بشكل كبير
وبشكل متزايدا نرى ان هذا العمل ليس فقط
اعمال طبيعه واجهزه
اعضاء الصناعيه
يجب ان تشمل ذلك كجزء من برامجها الذكاء
الاصطناعي